Speaker 1: . Donald Trump appears to turn
on his own anti-abortion supporters in a truth
central, post-truth, sensual, the truth, social,
or however you want to call it truth central.
Yeah.
That thing, the thing that's failing where
he is now blaming Republicans for taking too
extreme position on the issue of abortion.
Now, what's really, really interesting about
this is that, number one, it's enraging many
Trump supporters.
Number two, there's a kernel of truth to it.
But number three, it misses the really big
picture of why a lot of these Republicans
lost, which is that they were absolutely terrible,
terrible candidates.
So let's talk about it.
Newsweek reporting Donald Trump turns on his
own supporters over abortion.
Donald Trump has blamed the Republican Party's
disappointing midterm performances on the
abortion issue rather than the failure of
his endorsed candidate.
So the Truth Central post is as follows.
Quote, This is a beautiful New Year's message
from Trump.
Quote, It wasn't my fault that the Republicans
didn't live up to expectations in the midterms.
I was, too, 33 and 20.
That's his endorsement record.
It was the abortion issue, poorly handled
by many Republicans, especially those that
firmly insisted on no exceptions, even in
the case of capital R rape, capital ie incest
or capital l life of the mother that lost
large numbers of capital voters.
Also, the people that pushed so hard, hard
for decades against abortion got their wish
from the U.S. Supreme Court and just plain
disappeared not to be seen again.
Plus, Mitch, stupid dollars.
I think that something about Mitch McConnell
deploying money in what Trump considers to
be a stupid way.
So there's a couple interesting things here.
First of all, I just want to remind you, when
Trump touts that endorsement record of 233
and 20.
Remember, many of us could have that endorsement
record.
And what I mean by that is Trump mostly endorsed
incumbents, including some who were running
essentially unopposed in heavy red districts.
He endorsed the primary winners in red districts.
It's not difficult to rack up a lot of wins.
The important thing is that the critical races
that would have made a difference, the contested
races, Mehmet Oz in Pennsylvania and Mastriano
and Tudor Dixon.
Trump failed on those, and those are actually
the ones that really mattered.
But more importantly, Trump says, the problem
here was the abortion issue.
So there's a couple of things here.
First of all, is it true that running against
abortion, with no exceptions, is a bad strategy
for Republicans?
Yes, that is absolutely true.
There's limited appeal because it's increasingly
an unpopular opinion.
More Americans than at any point in the Roe
v Wade era believe that abortion should be
usually legal in most circumstances.
So taking a position of no abortion, no exceptions,
even in the cases Trump mentions, it is a
bad idea.
It's an inflexible position because you can't
end up compromising unless you want to look
like someone who's just putting their finger
to the wind.
When you say just no abortion, no exceptions.
You're starting from a point of lack of flexibility.
It doesn't match public opinion.
Sometimes focusing too much on a single issue
can hurt you because people see you as, Oh,
that's the abortion guy or gal.
You're not really going to deal with this
thing that's important to me or that other
issue or education or health care or whatever
the case may be.
So it is accurate that a no exceptions position
on abortion is increasingly out of step with
public opinion.
And it doesn't make sense.
But but but this is also part of Trump never
taking responsibility for anything and being
the victim.
It wasn't my fault.
He starts his troth central post by saying
they took these positions.
Well, you endorsed them, didn't you?
And the reality is, they picked terrible candidates.
Look at some of the people they selected.
Carrie Lake, a conspiracy theorist who doesn't
know anything about anything.
And she almost won, by the way.
Blake Masters for Senate in Arizona, maybe
one of the worst candidates in the last 20
years.
Mehmet Oz, a quack TV doctor, who, it's not
even clear, really lived in Pennsylvania to
fight against John Fetterman.
Doug Mastriano almost literally a January
6th rioter to run against Josh SHAPIRO.
Uncontroversial good candidate.
The right opinions on so many, so many issues.
Tutor Dixon Herschel Walker, who can barely
even speak.
So was it the abortion issue or was it really
an issue of poor candidates?
And I think we know the truth.
Abortion is important.
But the decision by the Supreme Court.
Was a little too early to affect the 2022
races as much as maybe some of us on the left
hoped.
And some of the Republicans, with that no
exceptions, view on abortion did win.
It was the terrible candidates that lost.
Now, in terms of the impact on Trump, supporters
of Trump saying this, the super pro-lifers
are not happy.
And it's sort of beyond the scope of this
segment to talk in more detail about that.
But they there are some extreme the people
for whom abortion is the most important issue
and they hate it and want no exceptions are
very, very unhappy with what Donald Trump
is saying.
We'll see if it affects his 2024 candidacy,
which is not exactly off to a brilliant start.
Let's now take a quick look at this humiliating
event that Donald Trump did on New Year's
Eve.